- This one I'm a little upset about.
- Oh
- [Kelly] Speaking of birthdays,
you recently posted a photo of...
This is for your 55th birthday.
(audience clapping)
If there were a cake here right now,
I would hold your head in it.
- I'll Be honest.
- I mean, here's the thing.
What I need to know,
this is all I need to know.
You work for that, right?
You work hard for that, right?
You do, right?
Oh damn, Oh no.
Oh damn, oh my God.
- Get back in the seat.
- Oh my God.
- Not that I'm bossing anyone.
- Do you not?
Is that DNA? Genetics?
- No. No. It's a
combination of many things.
But you see, I could do better than that.
- (yells) What?
- Of course, you see a muscle in there?
Do you see one muscle in there?
- Do I see what I dream of
looking like in my brain movie?
- Kelly, it took a hundred
pictures to get that one.
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
- the lighting.
- It took a hundred...
Look at my poor husband.
You can see his silhouette in the shadow?
You see?
- Oh I do, with the phone?
Oh, I do.
- Yeah, and he's covering
the belly with the shadow,
which makes it look more-
- Oh my God, the belly, oh.
- Look, look. It's (indistinct)
- I am looking. I wish you had one of me
in a bathing suit next to it to show you
- But it really did take a hundred.
- Hey, I never noticed that.
Let's talk about that.
That's actually really
cool, artistically speaking.
- I know
- He's the shadow on you?
That's really cool.
I never noticed that before
cause I was just so envious.
It's fine.
- And look at my face, I'm
like, life is great suck it up!
Suck it up! Hurry up take the picture.
- [Kelly] Take the picture! Yeah.
- I'm looking at the sunrise!
Take the damn picture already, you know?
- I'm just saying that's awesome for you.
What are things that you've
learned to not stress
about though, as you get,
like, you know, wiser?
As I age, I start to
worry less about things.
- It's funny because I worry
less about some things.
And I find myself that I get more anxious
about the little things that
I haven't been able to stop
stressing about, more anxious
which makes me more hungry.
(laughter)
as your metabolism actually slows down.
- Yeah.
- But I have to give
you this bad news, guys.
As you get older, you get more anxious.
- Really?
- Yeah. But I'm more wise
but little things that
didn't bother me before
start, they start to bug you.
For example, if I get the
window seat in the plane
I'm not as claustrophobic,
but now I just wanna eat
in the plane, I guess too many
times, you know or something.
But I really get very anxious now
I just wanna get there.
Maybe cause there's less time ahead.
So I just wanna get there every time.
But, I meditate and this
is what helps me a lot.
- Are you good at it?
I'm not good at that.
- I'm great at it.
- You are?
That's amazing.
- Not on the plane though.
- I gotta be honest with you.
Here's what I love about a
plane. Especially I'd lie
- The movies
- I'm like, I'm like, oh,
there was no wifi, that's so unfortunate.
So I can't do any work
and I'm just gonna sleep
or read my book or do
whatever that hell I want.
- But you can sleep easily?
- I can do, yes.
Yes, especially with a
nice glass of Pinot Noir.
- I'm hating you right now,
I'm hating you right now.
- Yeah, no, I find that
I'm the older I get,
I get more just like, I
think cause I was so much
of a people pleaser up
until maybe last year
but I find I'm getting better at that.
I find I'm less anxious, I'm opposite.
I think I was so wound tight before.
- Because you're still young.
You get less anxious.
- I'm gonna be 40 in April.
- And then you get a
little bit more anxious
because I might be working still very hard
and less of a people pleaser.
But then when you start
accomplishing that a lot
then you want, you are
less, how do you say?
Patient about people not pleasing you?
(laughing)
- I didn't talk about
that, that's different.
- That's OK too. Who understands
what I'm talking about?
There we go.